à Madrid devant les caisses de
nourriture les fils de la fin s'allonge
chaque semaine l'inflation record en
Espagne a poussé de nombreuses familles
à faire appel à l'aide alimentaire ces
ailes rouges orangés et ses plumes
noires n'avaient plus été vu depuis 1882
et au moment de découvrir les images de
ce pigeon faisant les scientifiques ne
peuvent pas contenir leur joie
aujourd'hui un foyer espagnol sur 7 et
victime d'insécurité alimentaire ils ont
multiplié les recherches sur l'île de
Ferguson au large de la Papouasie
Nouvelle-Guinée objectif repérer un
pigeon faisant à nuque noir
oiseaux très rare aperçu à une seule
reprise il y a 140 ans minute de silence
cet après-midi observé à l'Assemblée
nationale en hommage à ce drame qui
s'est donc déroulé je vous le disais
dans le Pas-de-Calais dans cette maison
hier vers 18h le propriétaire un
brocanteur reçoit la visite de deux
agents du fisc venus vérifier sa
comptabilité c'est alors qu'il est
séquestre les ligotes c'est un
effroyable fait divers un père de
famille sa femme attendait un enfant
donc c'est vraiment une tragédie on est
tous évidemment avec ses proches et ses
collègues qui sont sans doute très
marqués par par ces tragédies ces gens
de faits divers qu'on peut voir dans un
film d'Yves Boisset ou un agent du fisc
qui est tout d'un coup et
décapité par un
récalcitrant je trouve pas que que ça
soit très
ça éclaircit pas énormément la société
d'aujourd'hui ce matin le ministre des
contes publics Gabriel Attal s'est rendu
au centre des impôts d'Arras pour
soutenir les collègues des deux
fonctionnaires du fisc j'ai pour ma part
demandé que demain à midi soit rendu un
hommage à la victime dans l'ensemble des
directions départementales des finances
publiques dans l'ensemble du réseau des
finances publiques selon une étude plus
d'un élu sur trois dites à avoir reçu
des menaces ou des injures il peut y
avoir un climat d'agressivité par
exemple dans la même région dans le nord
de la France il y a une quinzaine de
jours à nos agents de Pôle emploi a été
agressé heureusement de manière moins
dramatique mais c'est toujours très
traumatisant qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
hier c'est la marque d'une
d'indurcissement de notre société d'une
montée générale de la violence et puis
du fait que le maire n'est plus
considéré enfin en tout cas par une
partie de la population comme
représentant l'autorité enfin une forme
d'autorité locale mais simplement comme
l'organisateur
de services qu'il faut rendre et auquel
les gens ont droit à la crise majeure
que l'on affronte et ça revient à votre
première question c'est la crise civique
qui se traduit par plusieurs phénomènes
des taux d'abstention Records qui
devraient obséder tout ce qui
s'intéressent à la vie publique et qui
aiment la République et la démocratie ce
sont des votes d'humeur d'extrême ce
sont des expressions violentes dans le
débat public souvent proportionnel à la
à la fin de la raison critique Claude
Guéant condamné à 6 mois de prison ferme
et à une amende de 30000 euros l'ancien
ministre est reconnu coupable d'avoir
délibérément minoré les frais de sa
campagne législative de 2012 une enquête
préliminaire a été ouverte pour
notamment détournement de fonds publics
à l'encontre d'érections
cette dernière aurait cumulé plusieurs
emplois à l'Assemblée à Nice et au
département des Alpes-Maritimes indiqué
ce matin le parquet national financier
300 gendarmes policiers et militaires
français sont affectés à la sécurité de
la Coupe du Monde au Qatar ces
personnels français vous disaient
vont-ils me permettre aux personnes LG
tes cuit à plus de vivre sur place en
sécurité pourront-ils brandir un drapeau
aux couleurs LGBT pourront-ils et elle
s'embrasser dans la rue sous la
protection et vous installez dans le
calme s'il vous plaît encore cet été on
a voté au Parlement un accord qui envoie
220 gendarmes français pour encadrer le
Qatar on va qu'ici opposer le
rassemblement national les républicains
et la majorité ou encore céder au Qatar
en aucun cas les policiers gendarmes
français ne font du matcha de l'ordre au
Qatar en aucun cas ils sont en contact
avec la police qatari pour appliquer les
lois du Qatar ils sont là pour protéger
nos concitoyens et pour nous aider à
mieux organiser la Coupe du monde de
rugby et les Jeux Olympiques autre
événement exceptionnel dans le port de
Dieppe vendredi soir un morse
visiblement égaré il est reparti le
lendemain matin